back in the day before a lot of my
videos were going viral probably one of
my first viral business statements were
get off the [ __ ] train JT called in
Jason Calacanis show this week in tech I
was trying to make a decision I always
talk about pondering and debating and I
just finally got fed up and I said dude
get off the [ __ ] train and people liked
it movie yeah okay so you got two great
ideas Gary your advice is flip a coin JT
I mean clear are you are you equally
100% all-in on both like Jason when he
gets you know pocket aces bullets he's
putting it all in or you hush equally
feeling that on both projects I am and I
knew you were gonna ask me that I am
passionate about about both contests so
dude honest and that's why I'm having
such a hard time you know what honestly
you got to get off the [ __ ] train and
just pick one you'll be fine
you like them both it sounds that way
okay James you take care man call in in
a couple of weeks and tell us that you
started if you're selling the [ __ ]
Rogaine don't call my week's tweet out
tonight that you've got it going